Kat Von D and steve-o have called it  quits sources close to the pair  confirmed to ET Tuesday that they have  in fact broken up though it's unclear  why or what led to the split the 34 year  old tattoo artist and her daredevil Love  had been dating for three months often  posting about their romance on social  media the couple had been linked since  November but first confirmed they were  dating in late December steve-o shared  this sweet snap of the two on Instagram  writing quote I know it's crazy that I  became a clean and sober hybrid driving  animal rescuing vegan who's super into  meditating but I'm glad I did I'm even  happier that I get to spend so much time  with a shockingly gorgeous and amazingly  talented woman who is all of those  things the two have since deleted all of  the photos they took together from their  various social accounts